a lot of you guys were wondering about
the kick-ass sound design that was in
prism
well I'm here with Rob crackle and he
was the guy who did all of that
who's the man behind it all the lasers
all the guns the hand-to-hand combat and
most of all the really awesome
teleportation sound effect that was
completely awesome actual like a lot of
the sound stuff I mean I know when I was
showing it to Freddie for the first time
he's like whoa those sounds
kick ass like that was like that was
like actually the first thing you
pointed out for the plasma rifle effect
what types of sound elements that you
combine well the plasma rifle was kind
of an interesting challenge because
there's like there's a lot of ways to
approach it
right one is that you start with like
real guns and from there the other is to
start with like synthetic stuff like
just synthesized static hits or sine
waves modulated stuff like that yeah and
I opted to go for the real gun what I
did was I took like a basic rifle blast
and ran it through a flanger to give it
sort of a pitching down like sort of
phasing sound to layer in which gives it
that sort of like a laser blast element
so that's like yeah going down I see so
to give it some beef I actually use like
an explosion I just rolled off all the
high end and so it's just that nice
round bottom nice that's kind of level
everything out the last element there
was actually - these were bullet
ricochets because they add a really cool
sort of high-end sizzle element I'm not
gonna lie I stole the idea from Ben
Burtt I've read a bunch of books on now
Ben Burtt did the sound effects of Star
Wars and you know he's mentioned many
times like how he iterated on the
blaster and one of the things he tried
was using ricochets and then did the
same sort of trick with the flanger too
to just accent that high end sort of
laser II sound that you can get
far as like using guitar effects or
musical instrument effects pedals for
sound effects one interesting note is
that all the voices for the the guards
and troopers in it basically what I was
doing for that is essentially I would
record myself for all them with Niko
having cameo or two and then I would run
that through a pitch shifter obviously
bring it down a bit and then afterwards
I would run the whole thing through a
guitar amp simulator essentially and
it's a very very very simple effect but
it's highly effective at giving like
this extremely kind of like you know
present like radio deep voice when you
heard the lasers in prison he was almost
like bordering I'm like painful to hear
but it's like all within the range where
you could like comprehend the sound that
was pretty amazing so like what like
when when you were making the laser
sound effects what was going into that
that sounds is a lot simpler than it
seems
the other stuff that makes it intense is
like the debris that's going on like the
tearing and ripping of the asphalt when
and then the building and a lot of that
stuff is like fire whooshes you know
done with the flanger or some other kind
of phase manipulation I tend to my
personal way working is I tend to start
with the low-end element first and then
move to the mid and then move to the
high what happens is if you start all
those things at once
it just becomes a mess you don't
actually hear the discrete elements and
you take all those elements and you
don't just line them up and say okay
they all start at the exact same time
you say okay well the the big boom is
going to start a little bit before
everything else and then
maybe the real gunshot a little bit
after that and then the laser stuff a
little bit after that it's more of like
you just play with it until it sounds
good
like yes of course as dumb and simple as
that sounds like that's a lot of sound
design is just playing with something
until you get this result that you're
using in your head the first thing I do
is in my head I try to imagine what
these things sound like and that's a
huge important step that a lot of people
miss they just start designing without
actually having a goal in mind oh yeah
it really is extremely helpful to like
have a goal in my leg even if you just
make mouth sound effects of what you
might want it to sound like that can
help this is kind of interesting it's
like a lot of it it's just through kind
of experimentation than exploration and
it's kind of like you have a vague idea
of what you're trying to do ahead of
time but it's like until you do it and
take a couple steps back and keep going
forward and like end up with the product
it like it it seems like it was really
easy at the end but like before we
started you had literally no idea what
you're doing Nick
just record stuff and even if you don't
think you're gonna use it right away
you're actually building a mental
catalog of all the sounds that you've
recorded and it's a lot easier to go to
your mental catalog and say oh I just
recorded something that might work for
whatever you're working on than it is to
like go to a library that someone else
made and you have no idea what's
actually in there or how they
categorized it or how they described it
pretty much it's like if you need a
sound and you're moving you can't think
of where to find it the best thing is to
go find something similar if it's metal
just find something else that's metal
that's kind of the same size and just
just do it yourself because honestly it
sounds just as good they kind of reminds
me of another topic I wanted to touch on
which is fully sound and very similar to
what you're saying about like just kind
of taking everything that you had at
your disposal when the recording sounds
that's pretty much how holy sound works
in that sense it's basically you look
through your piece you find certain
elements that need kind of like an extra
sound element behind them and just
gather them all up and just watch the
movie and record sounds into a
microphone as you watch it trying to
sync him up as best he can and I just
you know made similar movements
depending on what I saw on screen I sat
there with a jacket and each time
characters moved I would shift it
depending
if they needed to make a sound or not
and the same goes for a whole whole load
of other things there's a difference
between sound editing and so design
sound design you are trying to add an
emotional content to the sounds to help
convey the story to the viewer sound
editing is simply like Foley or simple
sounds where you're actually you're
dragging those sounds and you're just
taking them out of the library minute
that's sound editing so let's say you're
gonna take a gunshot and make that
emotional and elevate that to the sound
design level okay
what is something you like how what do
you want to think about when doing that
well you really want to think about a
gunshot what is a gunshot a gunshot is a
pop but what makes it scary is it the
fact that it's a pop no it's the fact
that it's gonna hurt somebody it's gonna
harm someone so what you want to do is
you want to like add something in that
has that emotion in it that has that
same sort of feeling something that's
pre-existing and like people are already
aware of something yes so like what
would it be an example of that an
example that is like a lion war or some
kind of dog
snarl like an animal or like even like
something natural like thunder for that
matter or thunder some kind of sound
that is scary to people on a more basic
level well thank you for stopping by and
explaining all this extremely valuable
information to the internets if you guys
have any questions about sound or sound
design you can hit Rob at Twitter what's
your Twitter name it's at Rob crackle so
they're right there perfect